hi guys so it's alabama here with my dad
and today we are going to be trying to
cover up his face tattoos with kvd's new
product
good apple travis barker's 15 year old
daughter
alabama gives her famous dad a makeover
that is pretty much it we did cover the
bus
and we covered this one by covering up
his signature face tats
do you follow trends or do you feel like
you create them i think it's combined
alabama enlists her dad blink 182
drummer travis barker
for her latest instagram video first
they test out different shades of kvd
beauty's
good apple skin perfecting hydrating
foundation balm
yes the viral beauty product is really
called that
i should just blend it right into your
skin so
where is your first tattoo back my first
tattoo was on my leg
which one's your favorite tattoo
probably the one we discovered
i mean does it get any cuter but now
we're gonna get this little
paper fish that's an anger babe
angry jeff i'm so sorry we're going to
be covering his hatred
anger it's an anchor
[Music]
okay that's just one layer it looks
great
okay so it does get cuter and
clearly that makeup works
he helped me learn about music a lot
she's seen it all so it's not like she
doesn't know what she's in for
back in 2017 the proud dad who shares
alabama and 17 year old son landon with
his ex-wife
shayna mokler was right by his
daughter's side when she debuted her
first official music video
our house which was shot at where else
her dad's house in calabasas california
it's a very fun neon video
do you have a favorite part of your
music video um
i think it would be driving my golf cart
because it's like the funnest thing ever
she grew up driving like quads and dirt
bikes
yeah and everything like that and she
learned at a young age like she would
drive my old cars but
back to those tattoos
the blink 182 drummer recently added
some new ink to his thigh
that says you're so cool and while fans
initially thought it could have been a
note written by his girlfriend kourtney
kardashian
he later explained on instagram that
it's actually a line from the 1993 film
true romance me and my wife were
minimum wage kids you know two hundred
thousand dollars it means a world to us
as for court earlier this month travis
opened up about his longtime
friend turned leading lady and why their
relationship
works during an appearance on the drew
barrymore show
i would you know like date girls that
didn't have kids and i find it kind of
hard because they would i think they
would have trouble understanding like
well why
why don't you want to go to dinner every
night with me or why don't you want to
see me every night
and now i'm
you know spending time with a woman
who's like a great mom
who's like a great friend and
i just you don't have to worry about any
of those things it just
comes naturally